magical speech causes things to happen
you utter a spell you utter a mantra
magical speech is active speech that
moves reality around well where in the
modern world do we encounter such
magical languages
no coding
coding
when you
type a line of code and then hit run
this utterance is not correctly
formulated unless something happens
it doesn't make a statement it causes
action and so in a way the most
positivistic of the positivists the
computer coder the the hacker is really
in the great tradition of facinian
natural magic and when a program is Well
written a reality
brings into being perhaps even a
three-dimensional reality that millions
of people can walk into and and with
force feedback gloves on can knock on
the walls and pick up the furniture and
look around so I think that the machines
are strangely enough the conduits of
this magical possibility and
um
virtual reality is our magical
Landscapes entirely you know there's no
laws of physics there no entropy
everything is under the rule of the
program everything is created and
maintained by language and my fantasy is
of and this is happening now uh to a
degree but it is what art should become
is people who build virtual realities
and then other people critique them and
then we produce a new upgrade and we
keep twiddling and making it more
psychedelic and more psychedelic and
more faithful to our intuitions and our
experiences and finally everybody will
stand together inside somebody's piece
of art and say you know I think we've
done all the good we can do here we have
we have made it real and each of these
instead of living in one world defined
by the laws of physics and the
inevitability of our personal deaths and
the second law of Thermodynamics and so
forth and so on we will create myriads
of Worlds some incredibly dark some
incredibly light some minimalists some
Baroque some described by terms yet to
be brought into existence but it will
all be done under the Aegis of language
and of course a computer program never
looks like its output it's the
underpinnings of the out but the output
could be anything from a game of pong to
balancing your checkbook but what the
artist produces in that case is lines
and lines of code and that is magically
empowered language that causes realities
to be to be changed
[Music]